la vie au château de Monte Cristo
raconté par des personnages tout droit
sortis des œuvres d'Alexandre Duma
pardon je me suis pas présenté je suisri
oui j'ai été marié avec Alexandre Duma
pendant 3 années le temps d'une journée
des comédiens costumés ont fait vivre
aux visiteurs une visite quelque peu
originale du célèbre château de portmli
où Alexandre Duma a élu domicile en 1847
pour fuir le tumulte de la ville au
travers de différentes scénettes les
personnages des romans de Duma prennent
vie comme l'agréable cardinal de
Richelieu personnage du roman Les Trois
mousquetaires
allez ah bah dis donc ils sont aussi là
que la monarchie C là que
diriez-vous d'une enseigne dans mes
gardes cette année le thème des visites
théâtralisées était la vente du château
de Duma après la Révolution l'écrivain
couvert de dette est contraint de vendre
ça de demeur c'est de rendre un peu le
tout interactif ludique qui soit un peu
accompagné qu' a du spectacle que ça
reste vivant ça leur permet vraiment
d'être impliqué dans la visite le fait
de les attraper comme ça avec des
personnages ça permet que même le moment
où nous on va pas être dans le château
on leur laisse aussi le temps de visite
nécessaire ils vont être plus curieux
ils vont aller chercher des détails et
justement depuis 10 ans la compagnie a
conquis le public c'est une excellente
idée pour pouvoir
Rymer la visite parce qu'effectivement
c'est une œuvre littéraire il y a
beaucoup de d'articles et de de choses à
lire dans Le dans les salles du musée et
donc avec les c ça permet de de casser
le rythme c'est très sympathique c'est
bien fait c'est moi j'ai j'ai bien
rigolé ces visites théatralisées sont
organisées chaque dernier dimanche du
mois dernier rendez-vous pour 2023 le 26
novembre cette année la demeure
d'Alexandre Duma a déjà reçu de 3 000
visiteurs